chassé of course was born in India by
the 6th century game of called
chaturanga and that game was a very very
slow developing game the pawns could
only move one square at a time the
bishops were limited on their diagonals
and the Queen and the king essentially
were paired they had similar movements
that mean the Queen was not powerful at
all well the thing that wasn't called
the Queen but the Queen could only move
one square and each direct one square
diagonally right you can only move one
square diagonally the bishop could only
move two squares diagonally it was often
called the elephant and so you can
imagine this game and somehow it doesn't
sound that much fun no it was very slow
it takes exactly a long time to finish a
game in fact that's the origin of
something that we talk about a lot today
tubby yeah when we talk about a opening
set position for it's unclear deep into
the bayonet attack or something like
that
royal players kind of trot out the news
quickly it's actually this old chest was
so slow and they really started from
these preset positions of tap yeah yeah
and the working the night moves the same
as they do today right so it's kind of
beautiful to go back a thousand years
and see these chest positions these
chest problems that you can solve
exactly with the exact same rules
because shadow room guy if they only use
their work in the night it's still
applicable exactly but the thing about
the form of chess that we play now
that's I see been around for over 500
years right and that came about with the
birth of the chess Queen which was
really the most prominent role change
that created us the game that we have
today
indeed the 15th century is really where
the French in the Italian school really
enshrined the rules in stone essentially
after that we've had five hundred years
of continuous play it was the French
with their own pissant
it was the Italians with the castling
but it was also the French with the mad
Queen they empowered the Queen
unbelievably with extensive powers of
movement that we have today and it
really strikes me that you mentioned the
madwoman's chess game because I think
that's that's so typical we mean get all
this power they make the world
right say she's crazy yeah yeah a rider
for having that great power exactly good
point good point yeah maybe that's where
it comes from it's 500 years old and
chess presented it it's really funny
because one of the things that we deal
with is like female chess commentators
female chess players is trolls people
giving their opinions about your moves
whatever it is how you look and
sometimes not so flattering especially
when you're successful okay and I think
this was the thing about the chest Queen
the madwoman chess Queen when she became
successful there was actually a critic
at the time and he created a chess board
with an insult for the Queen on each
square so it was like this engraving
this picture where it would say like
overly ambitious all these different
insults for the new chess Queen Wow
yeah and I was like I did an art show
recently in Boston with an amazing skull
for Donna Dodson and I redid this chess
board where all the squares were
actually YouTube comments mean YouTube
comments about female chess players
right and I have to tell you guys it
wasn't that hard to find 32 of them we
used me just put 32 on the the light the
dark squares and then we had me invited
people to write their own nice things or
insults that they had experienced so
what it really strikes me about it is
chess is just one of the only games
that's been around for so long in fact I
think the only game that's been wrong
for so long but still popular and the
fact that they just kind of like struck
upon it's almost like perfect rules with
the Empowered chess clean it's really
just amazing I mean it's kind of one you
you're you're big on chess variants very
much the rules if you're right but it's
kind of hard to do much better than what
we have no question about it
I mean chess has evolved these rules I
think Amazon is such an important rule
and yet we don't think about it because
we always grew up with a pissant but
imagine that it didn't exist how many
attacks you could shut down by not
having
all unlike who figured out that um
Poisson should be a rule so there are
this the chess has evolved into this
almost like really perfect game now
having said that the other games that I
think would compete with chess
backgammon is one of those games that
has also evolved there's many different
forms or variants of backgammon
but another game that you really have to
tip your hat to and say that that's a
great game the game will go by using a
great game and recently again they had
the alphago alpha0 chess program that
the google also to the go program that
just wowed the girl world absolutely
yeah it's funny that you mentioned chess
being this this perfect game because
even if you could create something
better than chess in my opinion it
wouldn't really be better than chess
because what you have with chances all
the history and there's lineage where
you can look back at players from
hundreds of years ago from games by them
and the birth of the chess clean in
particular is so striking historically
because it coincided with these super
powerful cleans in Europe such as we
novella absolutely no question about it
that's exactly right and also when you
think about the history of the game and
this idea that the chess rules today are
exactly as they were you know 500 years
ago then it's you can compare their
chess understanding in certain types of
end games or middle game or even opening
positions and how it evolved and you sit
there and you go oh my gosh so who were
the greatest players of the 16 17 18 19
century how would they compare the
impact of computers on chess
how has a chess changed women's life so
for example in the 17th 18th centuries
women couldn't go to the gentlemen's
club
there was the gentlemen's club you were
simply excluded from competing and
playing with with men
how have women's lives
in the last 150 years that's a really
interesting point because you know
Marilyn Allen wrote a whole book about
the birth of the chest wing and great
book she it's kind of more of not just
about chess in the history of chess but
also about the history of these queens
and Europe's yes both the 1500s and
1600s and she talks about how ironically
by creating this you know better chess
game women making the game of chess
better by having a female presence in
the short term it actually in some ways
stopped some women from playing because
the game kind of got sped up and
sometimes it spread to like tournaments
and gentlemen's clubs where there
actually weren't allowed so I ironically
like by becoming the most powerful piece
in the borage the game became a little
bit more masculine short term hmm so no
no good deed goes unpunished right so
and it would then then of course there
was a female player you know when I
think about the chess history very men
chick who comes in and people go oh but
she's really good I mean she could
compete with the best of men and that
wasn't so long ago so it was like even
though we had the birth of the chest
Queen in the 1500 wasn't until I'm gonna
just say the turn the 19th century that
female players are actually taken
seriously exactly yeah and you know what
before we wrap up the segment I mean one
of the things that has also really
intrigued me about the history of chess
and the rules is that even when the the
chess Queen became the most powerful
mm-hmm
when the pawn promoted to a queen there
was another queen on the board right
that was very weird to people they were
like ah can we really do that because
now the king has two wives that's not
okay they would actually call that
promoted Queen something different and
there was also some resistance to the
idea that upon which was thought of as
like a male foot soldier would become
female so even though one had the powers
of a queen
you didn't call it a queen right which
now as we see you know so many people
fighting for transgender rights and
LGBTQ rights we're coming back to this
and thinking like hey we
dick did all this yeah what do you think
about the game of Chateau runga
obviously the palms chest being a game
of war the pawns were infantrymen men
who literally carried Spears and the
idea that they could promote to a female
queen well of course there was no queen
in their game they're very intriguing so
the second Queen the promoted Queen was
called the promoted queen as opposed I
think it had some different regional
names but yeah there was resistance to
this idea and that's another play wives
we should just gloss over this wait a
minute let's give it some serious
thought I mean we need to get a second
King in there as well it's one of these
things where chess is ahead of its time
you know the the Empowered can the idea
that gender is partially a construct
chess predicted all this and hundreds of
years later we're still talking about
and we're still playing the same game
and I think that's incredible